[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france24 el
automovilismo ha sido un espacio
tradicionalmente dominado por hombres
este año del deporte en argentina sin
embargo dio un salto con un nuevo equipo
completamente femenino que compite en la
categoría top race juniors elbittar
tigers team en surgió como una idea de
pandemia aunque hay muchas mujeres que
trabajan a nivel zonal en algunas
categorías pocas hacen presencia como
mecánicas y como pilotos a nivel
profesional en este programa vamos a
conversar con tamara vital jefa del
equipo sobre esta experiencia por la
paridad pero antes vamos a conocer la
historia
es uno de los deportes más populares de
argentina casi todos los fines de semana
las carreras de autos o convocan a miles
y miles de espectadores en varias
categorías en todo el país también es un
deporte tradicionalmente masculino en el
que aunque existen mujeres pilotos
siguen siendo un grupo minoritario por
eso es un hito la llegada a este año del
primer equipo femenino a las pistas nos
cuenta más nuestro corresponsal a
natalio cosoi que fue al autódromo en un
reciente fin de semana de carrera
el volante lo lleva a una mujer pero no
es sólo el volante este es el primer
equipo femenino del automovilismo
argentino aunque hay algunos hombres que
colaboran es un equipo de mujeres algo
único sólo hace falta mirar aquí en la
zona de boxes para darse cuenta de que
éste todavía es un ambiente
mayoritariamente masculino para el
equipo vitarte y que comenzó a competir
este año la clave era empezar a darle
lugar a las mecánicas pilotos hay muchas
corriendo y a veces no se llega por una
cuestión presupuestaria no por una
cuestión de que una mujer nos anime a
manejar en una auto de carrera pero es
difícil por el lado de la mecánica no
hoy creemos que también hay un montón de
herramientas que te permiten y que
facilitan algunos trabajos que antes
eran de fuerza no así que bueno la vida
fue más que nada para empezar a darles
protagonismos a ellas en este deporte
que tanto unas vacaciones también una de
las mecánicas del equipo de victoria
pascual para llegar hasta aquí primero
hizo un curso de mecánica de competición
y después lo que hice fue un año de
experiencia en un equipo de horn por sus
prototipos
después de esto mi novia por 13 años y
lo ayudé
y después de corto la actividad hasta
que apareció
este es el auto que tiene a cargo y que
junto con el resto del equipo debe dejar
en óptimas condiciones para poner en las
manos de la piloto valentina funes hasta
llegar a visitarte y funes siempre había
trabajado con hombres también algo muy
loco y nuevo que quería hacer porque
quería saber qué es de qué se trataba
trabajar con todas mujeres y la verdad
que vengando nos llevamos muy bien así
que nada estoy muy contenta
para las piloto dos mujeres dicen los
organizadores la categoría top race es
un buen lugar para mostrar su habilidad
al volante es algo que de la categoría
de nosotros promovemos porque entendemos
que es una forma de generar la igualdad
entre el piloto mujer y el piloto hombre
y también desde nuestra categoría le
podemos dar esa igualdad porque los
autos motores cajas son exactamente
iguales y no existe una ventaja
deportiva de los mecánicos el equipo
evitar me está dando aquí sus primeros
pasos su objetivo es sumar más mujeres y
tal vez con el tiempo formar parte de
otras categorías de este deporte tan
popular en argentina y la conversación
sobre este tema es con la directora
deportiva del equipo tamara vitales
desde buenos aires argentina tamara
bienvenida a ellas hoy y hoy en día hay
aproximadamente unas 200 corredores
compitiendo en la argentina de donde las
motivaciones para conformar este equipo
con una fuerza fundamentalmente femenina
hola qué tal cómo andan bueno muchas
gracias por contacto antes que nada y si
somos un millón de mujeres corriendo en
el país afortunadamente es un deporte
importante en nuestro país en argentina
en el caso de nosotras estamos haciendo
algo súper importante que yo en el
primer equipo femenino siguen como
mencionadas hay muchas corredoras hay
muy pocas mecánicas trabajando así que
igual no hay que aplicar para este lado
ahora para más mecánicas
bueno uno de los obstáculos o incluso a
veces las excusas que existen contra la
pariedad en los deportes ha sido la
diferencia física entre hombres y
mujeres que compiten pues en diferentes
capacidades según sus condiciones
físicas pero cuando hablamos de
automovilismo pues no hay diferencia lo
veíamos en el reporte en vídeo
simplemente de conductores hábiles al
frente del volante entonces porque aún
así el automovilismo no es igualitario
aún está dominado por los colegas
hombres
sí yo creo que en nuestro caso en
nuestro país afortunadamente y como
mencionamos anteriormente
es bastante igualitario por el hecho de
que hay muchas mujeres corrientes hoy
estamos nosotras en una categoría dónde
hay cinco mujeres corriendo en las tres
divisionales
después bueno hay un montón en otras
categorías no lo que tal vez no hay son
mujeres trabajando en la parte técnica
pero era tal es más que nada por una
cuestión de fuerza como decías hace un
ratito del físico no hoy en día hay un
montón de herramientas que te permiten
poder trabajar a la par así que creo que
vamos como camino a un automovilismo un
poquito más igualitario bueno y cómo
pueden ustedes medir hasta el momento la
respuesta de los patricios
patrocinadores a esta idea pues que
nació hace recién también recientemente
bueno en este caso creo que es algo muy
distinto a lo que se vive en el exterior
en los demás países tal vez en los demás
países hay muy pocas mujeres corriendo
pero son auspiciadas y son acosadas por
los sponsor sobre todo en los femeninos
y en el caso de nuestro país nos pasa
que es muy difícil incluir a las marcas
femeninas dentro del automovilismo no
tales desde el lado de afuera de lo que
es este deporte se lo ve un deporte de
hombres todavía lamentablemente así que
si son muchos auspiciadas pero por
empresas que tienen más que ver con el
rol del hombre que con el rol de la
mujer desafortunada
es decir ustedes quisieran tener
muchísimo más apoyo que se viera más en
las promos y que se viera más en el
dinero en los fondos además de este
deporte que es carísimo más el apoyo de
empresas que apoyan productos también
para las mujeres
si nos gustaría que las empresas tengan
en cuenta en el automovilismo es un
deporte donde no sólo hay mujeres
corriendo y mujeres trabajando en la
parte mecánica sino que también vienen
díaz hermanas primas amigas y un montón
de fanáticas que son parte de parte de
este deporte no así que abrir un poco la
mente y no como no considerarlo
únicamente un deporte masculino que la
verdad que es un poco para el día en lo
que respecta a los país desde el
exterior no tanto de latinoamérica como
como vp o tamara que es lo que se
necesita para hacer una buena
competidora en automovilismo a qué le
apuntan ustedes además de ganar por
supuesto
y nosotras creo que lo más lo principal
es la fortaleza no la uniones del equipo
que nos comuniquemos entre todas porque
a través de la comunicación llegan los
buenos resultados también y obviamente
muchísima pasión porque si no tenés
pasión por el automovilismo es difícil
pues llevamos a cabo porque a veces el
auto te puede andar muy bien o te puede
andar muy mal en el sentido que se puede
romper algo porque no dejan de ser
fierros y a veces no lo preparan de la
mejor manera y puede jugarte un poquito
de mala suerte no o tal vez en pista el
hecho de bueno los toques con los
competidores los demás participantes en
la categoría pero yo creo que esos dos
son la clave la pasión y la unión es
súper importante y más entre nosotras
afortunadamente estamos
generando un lindo camino y aprendiendo
un curso del año
usted ha dicho en previas entrevistas
que cree que el machismo en el
automovilismo viene más de la calle que
de las mismas pistas y de los mismos
colegas porque como es eso
sí desde que formamos el equipo la
verdad que tuvimos muy buena repercusión
dentro del automovilismo se han acercado
muchos colegas a ayudarnos a aconsejar
nos estamos afrontando un proyecto
bastante complicado en una categoría
profesional donde hay que estar a la
altura y la verdad que con la ayuda de
ellos también podemos salir adelante no
tal vez nos ven haciendo un poco más
deporte quieren acercar con buenas
intenciones ayudarnos porque son cosas
tampoco normales para ellos no pero no
han recibido de buena manera y en el
caso de la calle me refiero a la gente
que circula en auto porque no tiene nada
que ver con el automovilismo como bueno
por ejemplo los sponsor no son los
sponsor femeninos que tal vez no no
conocen el automovilismo bien y bueno
tienen ese lado machista entre comisión
de industria les apoyamos en este
deporte no o la gente que anda con autos
que te tocan las cocinas haces y pasan a
ser también porque sos mujer man estás
manager bueno me refería a ese lado
el machismo desde el lado que no conocen
este deporte que la verdad que es más
que nada a pasión y que todos los que
estamos acá no importa que estos hombres
o mujeres que está delante
y los comentarios negativos de otro lado
como han sido
y luego por ejemplo cuando arrancamos
con el equipo y empezamos a salir en los
medios de acá
estaban los platos de plástico no es tan
bueno en la primera vuelta seguro van a
chocar o tipo comentarios así negativos
pero ya te digo tal vez son los que
menos bola le dábamos o no serán
indiferentes porque era de gente que
realmente no pertenecía a este deporte
no
bueno y la tarea más difícil que usted
nos mencionaba al inicio de esta
entrevista es la de incluir a las
mujeres mecánicas y a las mujeres
ingenieras porque además del tema físico
usted cree que ha habido otras barreras
que les han impedido ser más activas y
estar más presentes en el deporte de qué
manera no solamente con un equipo
femenino sino qué cambios se
necesitarían dentro de la estructura del
deporte para que haya más presencia de
mujeres ingenieras que son perfectamente
hábiles igual que sus colegas hombres
y en este sentido yo creo que vamos por
buen camino con el objetivo que tenemos
es más más mecánicas a lo que respecta
el automovilismo porque lo que va del
campeonato de esta temporada a nuestra
que han acercado dueños de equipos a
preguntar me conoces alguna mecánica
para que cuando
e implementar para que trabaje con
nosotros creo que eso es súper positivo
no apuntamos a que se generen solo
equipos femeninos sino que te pase esto
no aunque los equipos de hombres vengan
y nos diga hay alguna para recomendar
alguna que esté estudiando y demás
también la tendrá que ahí está hay
muchas chicas que nos están estudiando
metálica o que no no les gusta mucho la
mecánica pero por esto que se creía que
era un ambiente machista no pero a raíz
de esto hemos recibido muchos mensajes
de chicas que van a volver a lo que es
la carrera o que quieren venir a formar
parte del equipo
y ya para el cierre ustedes han sido muy
enfática en que esto de crear un equipo
femenino pues impulsa una causa pero no
es una invitación a segregar y a tener
muchos equipos femeninos para
diferenciarlos de los equipos masculinos
sino cupos justos o para que las mujeres
también existen en el fundamento del
deporte en que se basa ese discurso
cuando arrancamos nos decían mucho bueno
son las machistas porque se están
excluyendo solas hacen un equipo
solamente femenino
perdón pero la verdad es que si no hay
espacio para las mecánicas por donde
seguido arrancarlo
hoy el objetivo es ese cómo te lo plan
bien nuestro objetivo también es el día
de mañana poder atenderle el auto a un
hombre ser inclusivas nosotras también
tener unos mecánicos trabajando pero eso
va a suceder cuando más equipos
masculinos empiecen a tener en cuenta a
las chicas por lo menos en esta
categoría vamos camino a eso y esperemos
que las demás categorías los sigan
copiando y obviamente en todos los
países no
tomaron muchos grados un placer y
muchísimos éxitos en sus carreras
bueno muchas gracias a ustedes por el
contacto y bueno fuerza para todas las
que quieran unirse al automovilismo
esperemos que sea igual que acá y si no
tiene las puertas abiertas
muchas gracias a ustedes ya nuestros
televidentes que sigan en france 24 nos
vemos próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]